[Music]
caris be a joke
a very strained and they said II wonder
[Music]
you sure about this captain how do you
mean oh yeah what the [ __ ] out there
happy holidays youtubers is Charlie so
we got new alien covenant footage let's
break it down everybody like open their
face hugger present for Christmas this
is so funny
there are a whole bunch of other
trailers that are coming this week so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
make sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss out so you can
kind of see what they're doing here
there's a lot of the first three aliens
movies in this mostly from the first
Alien movie and then James Cameron's
aliens like you know colonial Marines
more action the first alien film was
sort of like this silent horror thriller
there was a little more atmospheric like
you had the crew of this freighter land
on this derelict planet and then they
discovered the alien egg and it all just
unfolds and goes to [ __ ] in aliens it's
more of a bug hunt like you actually
have military people on board that are
going to help a bunch of colonists clear
out the aliens they know a little bit
more about them so for those of you
asking about where this takes place in
the timeline this is a direct sequel to
Prometheus so there are two versions of
Michael Fassbender in here there's the
one with dr. Elizabeth Shaw that escaped
at the end of the film to go find the
builders homeworld like look where their
signal was coming from and then the crew
of this new spaceship has their own more
advanced version of his model so you
have to remember he's an Android
made by the Weyland corporation so this
new spaceship it's called the Covenant
that you know the movies called alien
covenant covenant is the name of their
spaceship like you hear them freaking
out is the alien starts to burst out of
that guy's back so the pitch is is that
bound for a remote planet on the far
side of the galaxy the crew of the
colony ship covenant find what they
believe to be an uncharted paradise with
the crew discovers is a dark dangerous
world whose sole inhabitant is the
synthetic David Michael Fassbender
survivor of the doomed prometheus
expedition so it sounds like what
happened at the end of Prometheus when
they took off they eventually crashed on
this planet we don't know where dr.
Elizabeth Shaw is but she's on the cast
list so she might be in like a prologue
she might be dead when this crew lands
on the planet
she might be somewhere else but now you
kind of see based on the pitch in the
circumstances that they find themselves
in that this is very much the first
alien film in the second aliens film so
sort of the Sigourney Weaver of this
movie is Catherine Watterson which is
funny because she was the person she was
like the main actress from fantastic
beast so this is what she looked like in
that movie this is what she looks like
in this movie you know very Sigourney
Weaver very badass I can't wait to see
her it's gonna be a lot of fun she looks
more like Sigourney Weaver in the second
movie in aliens like when she was
running around in the tank top with the
giant gun then in the first movie when
she was still just like the regular crew
member just trying to figure everything
out so like I said this is a prequel to
the first alien film so they still have
absolutely no idea what's going on with
the Xenomorphs but presumably David from
Prometheus will inform them because he
remembers everything that happened like
he'll give them the data that they need
Walter is the new version of the Android
like the Bishop version you know like
you went from Ian Holmes version that
glitched out tried to kill everyone in
the first alien film to the more
advanced trustworthy Bishop but the
funny thing is is because this is all
happening before ian holmes model has
been created maybe we'll see one of
these androids glitch out but for those
of you asking about James Franco he is
in the movie we don't know who he's
playing this kind of looks like him a
little bit he could be the guy that has
an alien bursting out of his back which
would be pretty badass like you know
very small role but very insane that
feels like something that James Franco
would be on board for Billy Crudup is
the one that looks down into the egg it
looks like he gets the facehugger
treatment so this is a bit confusing
this actor does not look like him so it
sounds like a couple people will get
base huggers in the movie but here's the
big question
do you think that this mysterious alien
paradise that turns out to be this
terrible terrible planet is the actual
planet from the first alien film do you
think that's what they're trying to
imply because the race of builders
seeded all kinds of planets like they
didn't just seat a couple planets
including earth that was what Ridley
Scott was trying to say in Prometheus
that there was this race of aliens that
was trying to seed the galaxy with life
a bunch of different planets so the
space jockey ship from the first alien
film is just one of many ships that they
have so I'll be really interested to see
if that's what the case is because
supposedly in the first alien film the
Weyland corporation had knowledge of
this alien planet in the Xenomorphs so
part of the mystery was when Ian Holm
was come
unike ting with the computer talking to
the Whelan corporation back home and
they were like no stay we want you to
find out what's going on instead of
bailing out like the rest of the crew
wanted so you don't really learn more
about their purpose until the second
aliens film like the Whelan corporation
wants to weaponize the Xenomorphs so
that sort of evolves over time as they
learn more and more about them so we
might see some of that teased in this
movie but it looks great it looks a lot
better than prometheus prometheus was
okay but overall I think the first two
aliens films are just vastly superior to
everything else so that's another great
question let me know what's your
favorite alien film from the franchise
and what do you think about them
dropping this on Christmas I just think
it's so funny that they dropped it in
like midnight on Christmas but in
related news there is a lot of other
comic-book stuff happening this weekend
I'm dropping some best of comic book
holiday stories as well as Justice
League trailer so we haven't got any
confirmation on when that is coming but
Henry Cavill just posted this picture of
him hanging out with the rock
mysteriously on Christmas like he's
literally saying that he in the rock are
just hanging out DC worlds collide he
calls out Black Adam by name in what a
coincidence that people were saying that
there's a Justice League trailer
dropping the weekend of Christmas and we
see the DC Illuminati just happening to
meet and hang out with each other at the
same time so just be on high alert for
Justice League trailer stuff it might
come Monday it might come a little bit
later but either way I think it's like
right around the corner and that's why
all these DC people are meeting behind
the scenes so I'll talk a little bit
more about that the next time I post a
DC video but I'm also working on some
Doctor Who Christmas special and
there'll be some Sherlock next week for
those of you that are asking about that
too while you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for my flash and
Justice League save Christmas video and
you can click here for my last big
Justice League teaser breakdown thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight